this week we're talking about AI from A
to Z I'm Carter Morgan and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news we created AI
hub to make it easier to collaborate in
the cloud and it's constantly evolving
more comprehensive labeling for assets
and the ability to favorite assets you
use regularly or just a few of the ways
you might notice a few changes to the
homepage to get the full brief on the
cloud blog if you're already using AI
platform prediction to run ml models you
can now take advantage of continuous
evaluation to keep those models in top
form will assign real human reviewers to
compare samples from your models to
ground truth tables giving you a clearer
picture of how your model is performing
across time it's on the tutorial check
it out speaking of better ml models are
you looking to analyze your
conversational experience to improve
customer satisfaction and get insights
in the top customer queries Priyanka
Vergara has a great post outlining how
you can send data from your
conversational experience build on
dialogue flow directly in a bigquery for
further analysis go peep that cloud
storage platform already makes it easy
to store your data but knowing how to
optimize your storage spend for your
specific needs that calls for a little
more guidance and we've got a great
resource that gets you started learn
best practices like setting up a
lifecycle policy then grab your broom
and dustpan and get to work if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see a full list check out the link
have any thoughts or ideas leave us a
comment or tweet us and in the meantime
we'll see you in the cloud
you